We've received reports saying
the roads have been blocked as well.
We got those reports too! They say
it's all ruins outside of Shibuya.
That's ridiculous.
That's not a terrorist attack, is it?
Terrorists?
What's that?
Are those guys inside there alive?
I detect signs of life.
It's a bio-cage.
As long as they're inside it,
they are alive.
You can ignore it during battle.
Ignore it?
What are you doing, Daisuke?
I have to save them!
You're not ready for that.
This is the first time
you're using a String Puppet!
And without a neurosuit too.
That lowers your power and speed.
If they're alive, I have to save them!
That's what I had been
working so hard for!
-What are you talking about?
-You told me to protect everyone!
Right now, focus on destroying the enemy.
Switch to burst mode shots.
-From that position, focus on its legs.
-I can't!
I'll hit the guys inside!
It will get you first. Shoot!
No! I'm going to save them!
They're more ignorant than we expected.
Okay.
-The connections!
-What?
If you destroy the two connecting points,
you can remove it.
Milo! Thank you!
There it is!
I did it!
Good job, Daisuke.
I defeated it.
Hey, Daisuke.
Wow, I am amazing!
Now, I can protect everyone!
It was just like what Milo said,
this is my destiny!
Are you hurt, Daisuke?
-Daisuke!
-I'm fine!